-My first guest tonight
is on Oscar-nominated actor
who stars in the new movie
"Hitman's Wife's Bodyguard,"
which is in theaters tomorrow.
Here is Salma Hayek!
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
Oh, so happy to see you.
Salma!
-Jimmy!
-Ah. Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
I appreciate it.
I follow you on Instagram.
And it's --
You're a good follow.
And you're really fun.
I just thought this was
very interesting here
on your bio here.
If you see -- It's all emojis.
-[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
'Cause you're supposed to
describe yourself.
And I'm lazy trying to,
you know, philosophize
and come up with a couple
of sentences about who I am,
so instead
I just picked all the emojis
that have anything
to do with my life.
And that represents who I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. A lot of things.
There's an octopus on here.
Can you explain the octopus?
-Yes. I'm a diver.
And so I have most
of the aquatic animals.
And I remember -- I've had
some encounters with octopus.
One that I really remember,
very clearly, is an octopus
that came and went on my mask
and started exploring me.
And you cannot panic.
-Wait.
-And you have to, like,
bite down on your bite
because they can pull it out,
or the mask.
And it was so weird what I was
seeing at the beginning.
Then it goes black.
But it was kind of magical
seeing it.
-Oh, my God.
-And then he went away.
I remember dating guys like that
when I was younger.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God. Oh, my --
Thank goodness
those days are over.
-...lot of memories...
-Yeah.
-You know, can I tell you
something really random
that I just remember?
My brother -- I don't know.
He used to call them Octopussy.
And I'm like,
"That's not a word."
But he kept
calling them Octopussy,
which is very inappropriate.
Never mind.
We're done with the Octopussies.
[ Laughter ]
-No, that's a James Bond film.
Sure, it's a word. Sure.
If we were playing Scrabble,
I'll give him the points.
[ Laughter ]
Also, you're in this
giant Marvel movie, "Eternals,"
and it just got announced,
and the trailer came out.
It broke the Internet in half.
Were you psyched?
I mean, did you go, "Oh, yeah.
I know how to do this."
Is it like another action --
I know you've done action films.
-No. I was shocked.
Can you imagine?
You get a superhero character
in your fifties?!
Mexican. Woman. In your fifties?
-Yeah. For you.
I would see you do anything.
You can do anything!
-I couldn't believe it.
-But did you have
any superhero moments?
You're in the movie,
and you got a -- whew! --
or a green-screen thing
or something?
Are you on wires?
What are you doing?
-My most exciting moment --
It was very unexpected.
Because there are superhero
moments, but the coolest one
was galloping in a meadow
with a horse.
And that's when
I thought to myself,
"Not only I'm doing
a Marvel superhero movie,
but I'm doing, like,
a really different, cool one."
-See? When we see that scene...
When we see that scene,
I'm gonna be clapping for you.
I love it.
This week, you star in
"Hitman's Wife's Bodyguard."
This is two of our favorites.
Ryan Reynolds and Sam Jackson.
Congrats. This is the second
one. They wanted more of you.
They wanted more of you.
So, yeah -- So you got
your own spin-off kind of.
-Kind of --
Well, it wouldn't have been
so hard to get more of me
because I only worked two days
on the first one.
-Yeah.
-But I was very lucky 'cause
now I worked the entire movie
on this one.
And I have to say
that I started practicing
saying the name of the movie
since we were shooting it.
Because I am dyslexic.
And "Hitman's Bodyguard Wife,"
"Hitman's Wife Bodyguard,"
"Bodyguard's Wife's Hitman."
I mean, I get really confused.
-"Hitman's Wife's Bodyguard."
"Hitman's Wife's Bodyguard."
-Bodyguard, yeah.
-Yeah, exactly right. Yeah.
And you play the hitman's wife.
-Exactly.
-That's right. Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
And Sam plays --
Sam Jackson plays the hitman.
And Ryan Reynolds
is our bodyguard.
-God, he is so funny.
There's a lot of swearing
in this film.
I'm surprised.
Samuel L. Jackson.
I know the --
But I was going to ask you --
'Cause I rarely hear you swear.
Did it rub off
on the real Salma Hayek?
-Oh, completely. Completely.
I have to be very careful
because I still have
a little bit of Sonia
that comes out here and there.
And I have my daughter.
And one time, I was just --
She just went, "Mom!"
And I said, "Oh, it was not me.
It was Sonia."
-Yeah. That's good, yeah.
-So now I use it every time
that I say something
that I shouldn't say.
I just say, "It was not me.
It was Sonia."
-Yeah, and it's kind of fun
to have a curse conversation
with Samuel L. Jackson,
isn't it?
-Well, it's fun,
but it was very intimidating
at the beginning.
-The best.
-I was like Robert De Niro
in "Taxi Driver"
in front of the mirror
practicing my "mother..."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, uh-huh.
-You know, because I have to
say it in front of him
a lot of times,
and it's quite intimidating.
-Yeah, yeah. It's good.
Well, we had a hard time
finding a clip
because there's so much cursing.
No, no. I'm joking.
I'm joking. It's very funny.
It's action-packed.
We have a clip.
Here's Salma Hayek in
"Hitman's Wife's Bodyguard."
Take a look at this.
-Come on! Let's go!
[ Engine revs ]
♪♪
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Take the gun.
-No, I'm not doing guns
right now.
[ Tires screech ]
-I got it.
♪♪
[ Gunfire ]
Wait, wait, wait!
No, no, no, no, no!
There's got to be
a safer way down.
There's maybe like a switch --
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-See?
-That's right! Come on!
Always bringing it.
We love you.
Salma Hayek, everybody.